hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to five nights at candy's
we're starting night for I've got
nothing else to say on the matter you
know the drill we're gonna play video
games okay hey all right here we go
hello hi my name is markiplier how are
you doing you have one hello just
checking in making sure you're a-okay
so remember that previous security guard
I told you about McDaniel so we got a
call from the police today apparently he
has gone missing
hmm I guess he actually was a bit crazy
I remember it when you say before his
last night a week yeah need to be with
him on his shift that night there was
something he had to show me I know it
sounds crazy right yeah although I
declined he still showed up for a shift
so of course the next morning we found
out the blank character had been
severely damaged then we checked the
surveillance equipment we found out that
he had bought a wrench and completely
smashed blank he'd also left the
building in the middle of his shift
after that I mean must have you know he
was nowhere to be found the next morning
Hey contact him or anything the manager
just fired him in 76 light anyway I'll
leave you to your work
yeah stay tight look again yeah he he
ran away he ran away and dope headfirst
into one of these suits probably all the
way over to Freddy fazbear's to find
another job
great cool great
Oh Oh God that was terrifying hi Jojo
get out of here they're really cramping
my style getting all up in musti's Oh
God
hey blank how you doing I'm glad he took
a wrench to your face you ugly [ __ ]
because I don't have time or patience to
deal with any of you therefore I'm gonna
deal with exactly none of you god damn
it where's where's mr. Wong huh oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh oh mama was
right outside my door I would have had
no idea I'm gonna just keep that nice
and [ __ ] that was cool we're good
oh my god this is not okay this is a
hundred percent not okay it's like a
hundred percent heart attack territory I
mean geez um x' g M&E christmas
golly gee gosh I think I can handle any
of this my hair keeps getting in my face
oh hello uh-huh oh fudge me in the
butthole okay cool all right all right
cool huh man I used a lot of battery
power it's only 2:00 a.m. at this rate
I'm not gonna make it I'm just gonna be
quite frank with everybody here I'm not
gonna survive tonight oh boy oh God okay
so I don't think mr. Momo is uh out to
play just yet again I don't know what
the penguin does oh hi how's it going
Joe Joe Joe Joe and Momo got the left
side on lockdown but so do I
normal out again I see MoMA back there
he's peeking his head hi mo mo how's it
going mo mo mo money mo mo okay
oh good in this neighborhood so far geez
man mama was quick like mo jump lit
three rooms it's only night for two what
the hell is going on here
good thing I'm able to conserve power at
this juncture
does that sound mean oh god where's Jojo
there's mo mo this Jojo planks not
looking blank doesn't want to play just
yet I gotta be very cautious about this
sorry we got off to a rather rocky start
I don't want to fail that's for goddamn
sure
oh come on Jojo still in the doorway man
they were there I got theories yeah they
went in an all-out sprint like right off
the bat what do you do I don't know what
you do I'm wasting battery power because
I'm always using the light what I need
to do is I need to be very sparing with
it hey how's it going momentum Oh moe
okay blanks still blank oh boy 3:00 a.m.
but I got more than halfway in my power
down so I think I'm okay
or I got more in half power left so I
should be okay so long as I keep an eye
on MoMA's mmm hey oh hey Pangu thank you
what are you supposed to be doing there
yes it's okay all right
I'm not sure what Pangu would do besides
just another animatronic unless he's got
another trick up his sleeve like he's
like a stealth one he comes in multiple
times in one session
don't tell misconstrue that in any way
please thank you very much I run a very
family-friendly channel in case you guys
didn't know about that
well you mean you didn't know oh well
that's that's your fault it frankly yeah
okay man I swear those first two hours
were way too much for me uh but Lisa's
all calm down try a second Oh God least
I can tell you guys a story now so what
do you want to hear stories of my
childhood man I used to go back into the
creek with my brother we never went to a
chuck-e-cheeses that's for sure like I
mean I don't even know like chucky
cheese are they really even still a
thing anymore is it prevalent I mean I
know I've seen stores here hither and
thither but I do not know okay Oh God
Oh God like seriously I'm like how long
were you there
Oh God I'll just move move man move move
you're patoot move your scooty platoon
oh god okay thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you ah the
par oh the power fluctuations not good
for me okay anyway so yeah me and my
brother we used to go on the creek a lot
you know we didn't get out a lot we went
to Dave & Buster's a few times but never
a chuck-e-cheeses I'm pretty sure that
the only animatronic experience that I
had is that this place called Jungle
Jim's
and I don't know how many people out
there uh-huh Oh God
huh I don't know how many of you out
there and even know what Jungle Jim's is
but it's this grocery store type of
thing but even calling it a grocery
store isn't it like enough to describe
it it's a Hey oh man it's beyond the
grocery stories it's huge it has an
international market it's got tons of
different varieties of food like
enormous varieties of food from all over
the world and they also have
animatronics oddly enough and I remember
every single time I went in junk
it was terrifying because these
animatronics were old and anyone who's
been to a jungle gyms knows what I'm
talking about and can confirm in the
comments down below that jungle gyms
their animatronics we're just about as
terrifying as anything that you can see
in five nights at Freddy's because
frankly oh man hey Momo good to see you
again because man jungle gyms they were
a little bit on the down side and and
they were huge like they were way bigger
than like your average person so I can
like it I can see how that would be
terrifying and you can imagine me as a
kid it's even bigger than that like
there was a lion I think it was a
gorilla and they were all singing and
dancing and I don't know what it is
about an animatronics and singing and
dancing they don't they don't need
singing dance they don't need that not
that important for everybody oh man Momo
is going quick it's almost time come on
yeah so but jungle gyms is cool don't
get me wrong I like me some jungle gyms
is fun-filled adventure like oh you can
get lost in the store it's so huge and
there's so many different types of food
they just like shop around forever and
ever and they just open the second one
yay Cincinnati and all that Cincinnati
has up yeah okay man I didn't I was
racking my brain trying to talk about
jungle gyms trying to actually
concentrate on the game here it was now
we're
oh boy well else we got do I even want
to know what's going on here Oh Oh
hi candy and Cindy are you about to go
into the meat grinding machine why are
you pointing at him what do they do
naughty naughty kitties bad kitties
naughty naughty what have you done to
anger the baby you should be ashamed of
yourself Oh God
Oh No ha ha hi are you doing
naughty naughty
el-hai tangu okay Pangu you have a good
day and half yes lovely day you have a
lovely day
okay so that was night for oh man I have
a feeling night fives gonna take me a
long time because that was chaos and
every turn so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'll move on real soon
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
whoa you're freaking weird no bad touch
bad touch bad touch